what is hashtag BTA let's talk about
that hashtag BTA is about getting you
motivated hashtag BTW is about making
sure you follow through on the things
that you said you were gonna do
hashtag PT is about keeping good habits
and it's about helping you get your
goals to actually become accomplished
I'm a big believer in visual cues and
whenever you have a goal or a habit that
you want to maintain the more you can
keep something in front of you visually
with a number the more likely you're
going to follow through on that habit so
hashtag BTA stands for believer taking
action what I want you to do is every
day come to the channel watch one video
and leave a comment and at the end of
your comment write hashtag BTA followed
by a number that number represents the
number of consecutive days that you've
left a comment on the channel so your
first day would be hash tag BT a 1 you
come back tomorrow this hash tag BT 2
and so on the reason why this is
important is because habits they're a
funny thing when you are on track with
one habit it can help you stay on track
with all of your habits and vice versa
when you fall off the track with one
habit you're likely going to fall off
track with all your habits so as an
example if your habits are you know you
want to wake up early you want to
workout you want to meditate you want to
eat healthy right now that's part of
your morning routine if one day you wake
up late then you're probably going to
throw the rest of the day away and
you're probably not going to meditate
you're probably gonna snack and not
stick to your diet you're probably not
going to work out because that first
habit that you started with didn't work
out on the flip side though if you start
with that habit every single day then
you're much more likely to stick to all
the other habits that you're trying to
keep I want to help you stay on track
with your habits I want to help be that
lightning rod for you so that you stick
to this one habit and you're much more
likely to follow through and stick to
all the other ones that you have set up
for your life so I want you to come back
every day leave hashtag BTA followed by
the number now a couple rules okay it's
consecutive days so if you leave 5
comments in one day they're all hash tag
BT the same number
if you do a lot over a series of say a
week you build up to the hashtag BT a
seven and then you miss it then you come
back the next day back down to one the
other thing I really want to encourage
you guys to do is support each other
because a big part about sticking the
habits and maintaining goals is having a
feeling like you're not doing this alone
and there's some external motivation
there's a group holding you accountable
so if you see somebody in the comments
and they post
hashtag BTA one congratulate them say
hey congrats on starting this new habit
if you see somebody reach a big number
there at hashtag BT a thirty or
something even bigger saying hey Wow way
to go congratulations just make them
feel special because I believe that we
have a nice community here you look at
the comments you look everybody leaving
all this great feedback on the channel
and I think we can all use that energy
and vibe to help us stick to our other
habits in our business in life and all
build bigger businesses so let the
hashtag be ta Revolution begin leave
your comments below and hopefully I'll
see you again tomorrow